Jim look this piece is totally slanted
it lacks in depth reporting it has no
sources and it makes outrageous claims
it's what we in the news world like to
call perfect now you're going to go a
different way with that Wow
thank you I felt really good about it
like a regular barb Walters so you
wanted to give me my press badge and
I'll head off to the big match yeah
unfortunately I can't do that
what's up your GPA too low exam grades
are posted right
she failed and passed Matt oh that bitch
Oh
[Music]
hygiene I can't talk right now oh are
you in a hurry on the way to the big
match yeah actually I am
ah ch what you posted our grades online
Billy I thought that you passed Matt
even though they failed how did you know
because I just copy us me
and he passed and I failed and now I
can't be the bob costas of the school
because my GPA is so low and it's all
your fault you stupid bitch Roxy play
death metal I'm going to tell them thank
you look I know what I did was wrong I'm
going right now to tell the ref doesn't
you oh you come and try will you Gina
please I'm sorry I couldn't hear you
what I said I I'm going right now yeah
stop it I'm going to talk about Medellin
Jackie Sam will you stop being such a
baby I'm a baby you have no problem
sailing miss baby did you Billy that's
because I expect more from you Jean what
do you let him Jake Nietzsche yeah you
keep you keep clear you keep swinging
Jake please - hey give me that hand the
filo thing I learned in your stupid
class Billy but ya know bad stuff has
been fair your wrestles way faster than
mine oh yeah you're right
I'll handicap myself no you have a metal
flagpole this is crazy
hey Judith hey my hen and lacks chain
I'll give it back you guys not have
anything more battle were these enough
nevermind
how do you know my name her in my class
you idiot you very sweaty him lift that
die slow see that doesn't make any sense
bitch I need my blog
new case of a TV that's why you don't
see mother but they still wanna be